cómo entender esta cantidad de símbolos
y de la llegada de maco saludando a los
espectadores si es bien diferente de
hace 5 años recordamos que hace 5 años y
manuel mejor había llegado solo y
entonces eso ya lo proyectaba como un
canto o un presidente y como él había
dicho de júpiter hub italiano es decir
que toma distancia con lo cotidiano sino
que manda desde toda su postura de
presidente es precisamente lo que le
reprochaban los franceses aquí tenemos
un cambio entonces llega en familia
llega con el himno de la unión europea
hay mucho muchas banderas francesas pero
también europeas
donde están los militantes y hay también
una dimensión lee a mí este discurso me
impactó primero porque fue bastante
corto tengo la sensación incluso un poco
más corto que la de marín lópez pero
además sin entusiasmo no estamos ya
estamos lejos de este este estado de
jubilación de perdón de exaltación que
había hace cinco años cuando marcó era
la promesa de una nueva política la
reinvención de la política no aquí
tenemos un presidente que es muy
consciente de todos los desafíos que
representan su adicción y que habla
entonces de un proyecto colectivo porque
como ya sabe que no puede ser cinco años
más de macorís ma